Yeah,
imaging technology is a,
is a wonderful enabler of disruption
because in the past the doctor could
only listen to find out what's going on
in your heart,
in your body,
or they could feel and they just have to
use their intuition is this normal,
abnormal.
They miss a lot of stuff,
but from a company in Seattle called
Sonos side,
as well as from a spinoff of GE medical
systems,
there are now little handheld ultrasound
machines that are very affordable for a
personal care physician to buy and
essentially what it is is a visual
stethoscope.
So instead of listening and feeling that
Dr just during a physical exam,
just looks inside of your body and,
uh,
and as a consequence,
they can see things much earlier and
take action mature earlier than you
could if you had to wait until a tumor
got big enough that you could feel at or
we're experiencing the consequences.
And that brings the ability to look
inside the body right to the doctor's
office for much more accurate diagnosis.
At much lower cost.
I'm in general imaging technologies have
preempted what we used to call
exploratory surgery.
When you couldn't look inside the body,
you had to cut it open to see what's
going on and now just being able to look
makes it a lot more affordable and
simple.
Now those machines are very expensive
and so you have to go take your problem
to the solution,
but their technology is in development
now that will decentralize the ability
to look inside the body like this little
handheld ultrasound.
The other exciting one is the advent of
molecular diagnostics.
Um,
it turns out that the body has a very
limited vocabulary,
but it can draw upon when it needs to
express that something has gone wrong
and the body's vocabulary are,
it's physical symptoms.
The problem is there just aren't nearly
enough symptoms to go around for all the
diseases that exist.
And so the diseases had to get together
and agree to share symptoms of.
The problem then is when you diagnose a
disease symptom and it's caused by
multiple different factors,
you cannot have a rules based therapy
because the therapy that works for one
patient who's been diagnosed with that
symptomatic disease may not work for
another patient.
Because there are multiple causes of
those symptoms and before we,
we didn't understand that care could
only be provided through the wisdom and
the experience and intuition of highly
trained doctors,
but the genomics revolution has really
enabled us to understand at the
molecular level what these diseases
truly are now.
So for example,
we thought there was a disease called
type two diabetes
diagnosed when you've got elevated
levels of glucose in your blood.
Turns out that there are about 20
different diseases that agreed to share
elevated blood glucose as their symptom.
And so in the past you couldn't treat
all type two diabetics the same way
because the response was highly variable
and now we understand,
oh gosh,
it's because diabetes isn't the disease,
it's those causes that are the disease
and molecular diagnosis is enabling us
one by one to figure out exactly which
of those you have that then is the
precursor or the prerequisite to the
development of a predictable therapy.
Um,
cancer is going through this transition
in just a marvelous way.
So we used to diagnose cancer and define
the disease by geography.
So you had brain cancer,
blood cancer,
bone cancer,
breast cancer,
and you would treat patients who were
diagnosed in that way with a radiation
or chemotherapy.
One patient would respond and then the
next patient wouldn't respond to the
very same therapy and so you just had to
leave it to the intuition of the best
doctors you could find,
but now we understand that that's not
the disease.
In breast cancer,
for example,
there are about six different tumors,
each of which can be characterized by
the unique molecular pathway by which
the tumor propagates and so there are
six diseases there in that location.
Not One,
but understanding them that you've got
these different types of tumors,
allows you then to begin developing a
therapy that is appropriate and
predictably effective for that type of
tumor and it turns out that each of
those types of tumor doesn't.
Tumors just doesn't rise only in the
breast but arises elsewhere in the body
as well.
And so our ability to cure cancer or to
put it into long term remission is much
greater now than it was 10 years ago
because of these molecular diagnostics.
Cervical cancer now is a very well
understood disease.
We understand its causes,
virus in care at that point when you
have a an ambiguous diagnosis followed
by a predictably effective therapy and
nurse can actually provide that care
just as well as the doctor could,
and that's very exciting.